Los arrecifes de coral son parte
de los más espectaculares
ecosistemas del planeta;
Son también unos de los más vulnerables.
Pero, ¿Cómo podemos proteger los arrecifes
y los animales y plantas que dependen de ellos?
Y ¿cómo podemos asegurarnos de que nuestras áreas protegidas no sean perjudiciales
para las personas que utilizan
los arrecifes para sobrevivir?
Estas son algunas de las grandes interrogantes
que enfrentan hoy los biólogos de
conservación marina.
Tomemos a Fiji como ejemplo.
Fiji se compone de una serie de islas
en el Océano Pacífico Sur.
Para ayudar a equilibrar las necesidades de conservación y de sustento.
los científicos sugirieron que en lugar de un gran parque,
que provee muchísima cobertura para un sistema de arrecife
mientras deja al resto desprotegido,
una mejor manera, es crear un sistema de áreas protegidas
anidadas juntas como perlas en un collar.
Esta idea es denominada conectividad,
y de esta manera, los científicos pueden proteger muchos hábitats diferentes
a la vez que no excluyen a las personas de sus tradicionales bancos pesqueros.
La única manera de que esta red de reserva tipo “collar de perlas” funcione
es conectando cada parque con los otros parques.
Hay dos principales beneficios de esto.
Primero que todo, protección.
Si algo malo ocurre en un parque,
digamos, un derrame de petróleo
o decoloración de los corales,
entonces, puesto que el parque
es parte de un sistema,
puede ser retirado de los parques
que se libraron del evento.
El segundo beneficio es la representación.
Mediante la conservación de muchas áreas diferentes,
los científicos se aseguran que muchos hábitats diferentes estén protegidos.
De esta forma, se pueden asegurar de que todos los diferentes hábitats marinos en Fiji,
tales como arrecifes de coral,
manglares,
y lechos de vegetación marinos,
estén todos bosquejados.
De esta manera, no colocamos indebidamente a ningún pueblo en particular
o grupo de personas bajo la carga económica
de tener sus bancos de pesca fuera de los límites.
Al compartir la costa alrededor de las comunidades,
ellos además pueden compartir los beneficios.
Entonces, si acordamos que en lugar de un gran parque,
debiéramos tener muchos parques de diferentes tamaños
y cubrir diferentes hábitats,
entonces, los científicos deben asegurarse
de que aquellos parques más pequeños estén conectados,
porque si no lo están,
probablemente no serán autosustentables.
Pero, ¿Cómo lo sabemos?
Aquí es donde entran la genética y el ADN.
Al observar cuán estrechamente
relacionados están los peces
recíprocamente en cada una de estas reservas en Fiji,
los científicos pueden comprender
precisamente cuánta migración
procederá entre las reservas dentro del sistema.
Ahora, es importante observar a una variedad de especies distintas
porque no existe garantía
de que lo que sucede con estas especies
es lo que suceda con estas otras especies.
Pero, si observamos detalladamente bastantes especies,
podemos distinguir si el collar está funcionando o no.
Lo que los científicos han descubierto, hasta ahora,
es que, en general, existe una buena suma de conectividad
entre los parques al interior de Fiji.
Pero esto no es precisamente una gran libre competencia;
más bien, se cree que algunas especies,
recién nacidas en el extremo occidente,
tienen dificultades
para llegar a las islas en el extremo oriente.
Para ayudar a lidiar con eso,
los biólogos de conservación sugieren
que existan suficientes parques tanto
en el oriente como en occidente
para mantener saludables a las poblaciones.
Esto no es tampoco solo en Fiji.
Instrucciones acerca de la conectividad en las reservas, pueden ser de ayuda en todo el mundo,
en lugares como Indonesia,
Papua Nueva Guinea,
y Las Bahamas.
Los científicos están utilizando
una variedad de herramientas
para ayudar a comprender
cómo los parques individuales
pueden funcionar juntos,
a fin de que, su suma sea mayor que su totalidad.
Y de esta manera, podemos mantener el bello collar
que es nuestro arrecife de coral, intacto.